skate finally has an update the gala
horn is getting a different kind of Nerf
and the Samsung gaming Hub is live all
this on today's Gamespot news
[Music]
behind the new skate released a fun
update video to announce an upcoming
play test the video claims to feature
pre-pre-pre-alpha footage initially
showing off very Bare Bones levels and
character builds which get into a ton of
accidents before transitioning into
gameplay resembling something you would
expect to play at home all the while
talking about how the team is
implementing a lot of fan ideas into the
game highlighting some of the creative
designs that seem ripped from a
potential level Builder indicating that
skate 3's skate park mode could be
returning for the new installment it's
been 12 years since that third entry's
release and after fans champped at the
bit for a fourth skate EA finally
answered their prayers at its 2020 EA
play showcase today's video is the first
real update since that announcement and
anyone that wants to help shape the game
can sign up to be considered for play
testing at skate.game forward slash
insider Destiny 2 players that have
acquired one of the game's most iconic
weapons the galahorn rocket launcher
will have first dibs on a nerfed version
of the weapon no not a less powerful
in-game gowerhorn an IRL Nerf gallahorn
blaster Early Access pre-order Windows
starting July 7th and ending July 21st
will be available to anyone that has
acquired the in-game digital gallarhorn
via the Bungie 30th Anniversary pack
remaining units will be available to the
public after that initial pre-order
window the rest of you get Shadow white
I guess head to gamespot.com for a guide
on how to acquire the in-game weapon to
get ready for the pre-order window this
isn't some toy for children this Nerf
gallahorn is four feet long which means
that it is a one-to-one replica of the
in-game Exotic I cannot wait to see
someone remake this video with it
foreign
[Music]
all of this awesomeness does come at a
price however retailing for 185 dollars
inflation Has Come For enough too it
seems after spending all that money on
the Nerf gallerhorn you might not have
much of a budget left for games or
consoles in July however if you have a
recent Samsung TV and a Game Pass
ultimate subscription then you're in
luck no need to buy games to play or a
console to play them on as Samsung's
gaming Hub is now live connect any
Bluetooth controller to a 2022 Samsung
TV and you'll be able to access the Xbox
game pass Library via Cloud streaming as
well as other similar services like
Google stadia and GeForce now with
Amazon Luna support coming soon this is
just one step for Xbox bringing cloud
gaming to TV in June 2021 Xbox did
confirm that it was working on a device
akin to an Amazon Fire TV stick Windows
Central confirmed this may with the
company that they are taking a little
longer than initially plan and to bring
the product to Market but when it does
become available to Consumers
theoretically any TV should be able to
support Xbox cloud gaming
that's everything for today's Gamespot
news remember to go sign up to play test
the new skate as well as check out
gamespot.com to learn how to get early
access to that awesome Nerf gallop
[Music]